ouch to my left it's my great pleasure
to welcome it Agha Keshawn legendary
game designer now with Valhalla game
studios to talk about Devils third
aragaki-san welcome and joining him are
Scott reaching it's from Nintendo and
Danny Bilson also from Valhalla games
you guys so psyched to have you here
we're gonna look at some Devil's third
it's gonna be pretty nasty from what I
gather all right pretty fun
alright so we're gonna start off with
the trailer I think so people can get an
idea but it a gawky son what yeah what
kind of what do you want to do here with
Devils third what what kind of
experience you trying to create for the
player never something okay um don't
know it's pretty tight oh my god oh no
soot on the schedule so Pontiacs oh no
solace near ninja fighting unihoc condos
Rossini also the stoker they derived
jnana
avionic uno octo the snare oh sorry
Maxon you assume as teeny romantic
artists immanence cute item we muster so
what we're going for here is a modern
shooter with lots of different action
elements you've got the hack and slash
swordplay that you might find in the
Ninja Gaiden series as where as the as
well as the kind of bare-knuckle
brawling melee that you would see in a
Dead or Alive game and put all that
together and crank it up as much as you
can that's casting the net pretty wide
the melee attacks and the gun fighting I
that it's always tricky to balance those
things I'm excited to take a look at the
gameplay demo you guys have for us but
first let's roll a trailer of Devils
third and we're gonna get a look at sort
of what the game setting is and what the
tone is I sound good
alright so that should be coming down
the pike here we go if you want to give
us any background on what we're seeing
here feel free to chime in at any point
gentlemen
oh that was just your sizzle reel for
the studio I was looking cool I was like
wait a minute
we're on a ship here Viking time oh no
now here's the cranking it up to as much
as possible stuff you were talking about
before
that craft up from the sky passenger
trains polite the earth is not doing so
well okay all right so competitive
multiplayer a big part of Devils third
and explosive as well it seems
well you you know that's sort of that
that view of the the Midwest of the of
the map it looks like yet some sort of
territory control going and there's the
whole owning the map component to this
game it works on many many levels the
shooting dudes in the head level of
course is one of the more important ones
and there's more along those lines so
we're seeing a lot of shooting here a
lot of competitive action is this the
same kind of pace of action that we see
in the single-player campaign as well
yes that's correct
here you see the ability for clans and
teams to earn and unlock not just
customization but base units as well
certainly having a fun sense of humor
with the different outfits here I like
it
how could you point a gun at a kitty
facemask I'm sorry these guys are
throwing fruit what is yeah we got here
in this mode each player has to get
their fruit in the blender and defend
against other players getting their
fruit in the blender not to mention what
happens when a player winds up in the
blender Oh a player's in one up in the
blender of course why would you fine on
I that person has the rainbow chicken
powerup I
it seems very formidable obvious this is
honestly it's been a long time since I
looked at the trailer for a multiplayer
game and burst out laughing I like it I
like the attitude and there's that melee
you were talking about he gets
so how many players are facing off in
these conflicts 16:16 nasty and some of
them are dressed as ninjas and some of
them are dressed as soldiers in 1704
yeah yes lots variety so it seems it
seems to like you guys you know having
fun is a lot of a part of this game time
machine didn't actually think I got the
day off
not just the player having fun playing
it but also you guys having fun with
video games and the video game
conventions and different elements that
that go into them that's right it looks
like it definitely had a good time I
mean many on there no it's supposed to
do you think they what are they yeah I
try to remind everybody as often as I
can not to take it too seriously and
keep it fun you know multiple Cara Oh
since second inning look it's critical
and I'm sure that a lot of people are
watching our thinking what is this but
we're happy to create those kind of
mysterious questions in their minds I
think it builds anticipation yeah you
know that it's much better to look at a
game and think what is going on then to
look at a game and feel like you know
everything that's happening because
where's the mystery
no no not you know honey I know
Kiyomi naina you can see the snare of
course alright so that was a look at the
multiplayer trailer and of course that's
this game is coming only to the Wii U I
think we're gonna try to jump into
actual gameplay of the single-player
campaign now see you are a single player
no game parade Neha Dimas name isoka yes
there at so can you set it up for us
where are what is the setting for what
we're gonna be seeing in the campaign
well that's all said they know - ah -
johor manicotti wants to show car oh
okay no saki neomi sister Karen a unknow
system am I so right hi so yeah go ahead
and explain a little bit after it's up
today it's not a surgical do they say
alright here we see a guy not exactly in
a regulation uniform not good enough
Akutan is neck
Acharya moto moto freezin Ananda knee
high
yes he's actually a former prisoner and
why is he shooting the people other than
the obvious reason that they are trying
to shoot him Hokkaido kini don't open
any more production idea busan star what
a motorbike anderson yeah so they have
screwed over democracy in on this so
after the fall of the USSR a lot of
these former soviet military members who
couldn't go anywhere else banded
together and formed formed a terrorist
organization called s oh dear or a
school of democracy school of democracy
that's right it seems a little
misleading I don't know you know my this
whole company democracy now so no a
Saudi score over a cigar games oh no so
no bardotta Oh Hank oco-2 sturua
christening so no tameni
kerosene guramukh or ATO EMP Oh skill
boost Algirdas so this school of
democracy has destroyed a lot of
communication satellites with a debris
field called the Kessler syndrome and
also ignited emps that have taken out
the electrical grid all over the world
trying to destroy the current world
order and replace it with their own dona
moça today old Scavo tamanegi negative
ah
I'm gonna call you a bee you maybe to a
pioneer you gave us car Gautam on the
Agena for any cross the range there no
any infantry you know combat Allah how
does it matter look at the sea so that
means no one's able to use any of their
electronics cellphones UAV things like
that in fact no modern weaponry can be
used so the world has to resort to these
infantry level skirmishes and which of
course involves giant swords absolutely
mother Clark's Enochian a katana modem
as me
well here we see some melee combat in
action and what you know it Agha ki-sun
you obviously have a long history of
melee combat that are alive and ninja
gaiden what he when you are taking it on
for Devil's third what is the feeling
you want to create and how is it sort of
different from what you've done in the
past
sake no game interprete gonna made a
combat role especially on the show God
ever saw the demo on Ojibwe no Paco
Munakata soy de Navarra mama de no no
ceremony alto de Guinea are irrevocable
oh so you might have noticed a little
earlier that Ivan through his weapon to
kill an enemy and now he has no sword so
he's engaging bare hand and stole a
sword and killed that enemy with his own
sword he's got a sword now oh you know
these don't always go well for you when
you try to steal swords from guys with
guns
Tommy also anonymous man what kind of
Gilbert there so Nova Kyriakos scotoma
dekiru
that put automatically I'll say it's you
know Stacey nickimja so so yeah you can
definitely steal enemies weapons we're
gonna take a look at the next stage also
what kind of you know we saw it we saw
the player get vanquished by enemies but
we also saw the player killing a lot of
enemies and what kind of balance do you
want to strike here between you want the
player to have a lot of fun when playing
but you also want to make it a little
bit challenging
what's what's a bigger priority for you
though you need money dole that insult
almost a mustache okay Bob
Ryoga oh sorry no no a toes in the skid
or Japan yuan nan Chi cry okay so if any
congratulate the soccer mom rainy moose
cash captor are punished can i'd tomo ni
the chakra no garage could escape the
mascara
no noggin are on or learning kabocha
difficulty in consular llamada
URI Scottish Tomas yeah we we like to
look at the game from a learning curve
perspective so long as players can stay
on that curve we think it's a lot of fun
but if they start to fall off or if it's
too steep then you're running into
problems we want to make sure it's an
enjoyable experience we're paying a lot
of attention at this time so no DNA no
no Nintendo version in Chicago Stewart
in a monkey Nintendo no Nintendo places
to go constitutive of the law so another
you okey this feel and our partnership
with Nintendo has been especially
fruitful in that particular area we
found that we've been able to learn a
lot from them and their expertise on
that well I'm interested to ask you
about that because devils third is a Wii
U exclusive and so when a game is coming
to the Wii U you have the capabilities
of the Wii U at your fingertips you have
the Wii U gamepad with motion sensing
and stylus interaction the touch pad are
there ways that Devils third is using
these capabilities of the Wii U the
prasada we send you on a node and a toe
GRC talker motion control on adults
garmiskar a DHCS by misil I also know
infantry team factory not sushi in Vista
Connie Arriva sake she's only monkey
referee Donoho Cooper only hepatitis
star her own personal appetite apart a
nice guy so typical all they know and
communication its famous yeah so we are
in fact building elements for use on the
gamepad battlefield communication is
going to be a really important part of
multiplayer especially because infantry
needs to share information and
communicate and so all across North
America you're going to find these
ground bases and these forces need to
communicate with one another to make
their efforts successful beyond schema
stuck on in on beam each ago b25 girl
papadum that is enough to put over gonna
be no monkey monster linear program i
got ah I don't know if you saw a little
earlier but there was a b25 used in a
propaganda poster I did see the
propaganda poster splash across the
screen
so I do you take your inaudible time
with the key the city also no sales on
Gaiman on the snare so part of the war
effort is these various factions have to
recruit people to join their side to
fight and defend themselves against
other factions now that sort of the
battlefield communication the different
factions Dani I think that gets at what
you are mentioning during the
multiplayer trailer that meta game of
territory control so is that a theme
that connects the single-player and
multiplayer campaign
yeah well both games absolutely exist in
this same world post technology world
which allows the most important thing
and the base of this game is range
combat sword combat melee and we haven't
seen it yet but the stuff he's famous
for is the way the control fields and
the movement of the player up walls the
multiplayer game honestly is the only
game I've ever jumped on to a friend off
a rooftop and cut off his head and it's
a very unique experience and absolutely
hilarious ultimately and it's over the
top nature and sort of parody of
violence and violent art that sounds
like a pretty good way to to quit
yourself in a multiplayer match it
really is we've played this game for a
very long time back into the studio in
Los Angeles and the lab laughing fun
more than the intense competition is
combined with a lot of just good times
and good humor by the nature of the
mechanics he's given us to play with
here
speaking of mechanics and I noticed
occasionally when he's taking cover like
this instead of reloading his gun he's
just lighting up and having a quick
cigarette well sometimes it takes a
drink to tobacco cessation second the
host of a few drinks as well there's a
lot of vices that have to be consumed in
the arrest moments of combat you got to
keep your energy up somehow I guess and
then he goes home a turret that was a
particularly brutal sort of slow down oh
actually now sorry let's switch to the
weapon let's talk about weapons
the tomahawk obviously very you know
built to be thrown the katana maybe not
so much but will you be finding a lot of
different weapons in the course of the
level or do you have to decide what
weapons you want from the beginning made
a new book you don't know either so
let's get old tomahawks matter yeah
buddy nugget I eat old boy what's in
here yeah don't you know yet engine I
gonna cut it off yes you can certainly
throw the tomahawk yeah that was nice
and this is you know I love it it's not
you know so many games like this with a
cover mechanic you just want to sit
behind cover and pop out and shoot and
pop out and shoot but running at a dead
sprint sliding and then beating the crap
out of a guy that's pretty fun too
it's a no cover shoot that don't cut off
my momaday United room let's get over
what you got buddy actually today
khoresht ie do you know this name thank
you mouth man yeah you certainly do want
to run around but there definitely some
times when you need cover
oh well and sometimes when cover is
apparently being blown up
do you guys with a lot of the emphasis
on being over-the-top and having a lot
of explosions do you do a lot of
environmental destructibility and stuff
hey come Co no object them all [ __ ] I
decided do you know
yeah you're definitely gonna see a lot
of destructible environments especially
in multiplayer where people can
customize their own fortresses only to
see them blown up yeah I imagine that
would be a real heartbreak well then
someone in Jubilee study studying uh
what it is so that's I'm located listen
in everyone's gonna be able to make
their own camp with a fortress yeah yeah
we saw that in the trailer a little bit
moving around the building there's
placing them down what is the the goal
of doing that what's your motivation is
it just you want to create places where
you have the advantage or is there some
other strategy at play it customized
sort of oh yeah party on I'll send up go
thinking ah motivation God you're on
stop so did them all that scheming
Souter decade to you know Sonya girl ma
does she know ye sports like you know
say yeah so yeah there's definitely a
strategic element you want to choose the
layout that is going to be advantageous
to you to protect your territory and if
you protect your territory then you also
need to assault the enemy territory as
well what do you get when you aside from
the satisfaction of just burning your
friends stuff down what do you get when
you conquer an enemy territory taking no
Chico sympathy that I might throw you
beating got Iman
Oh Takeo Tata Bonnie a soulless name on
a Jew Samaria in Missoula character in
the snake substitutable Artemis the
Pocono takes a fool
think of the bar so it takes up its top
Sparano host you got submit their formal
training hydrologically so there are 13
areas in the game divided across like
geopolitical lines
cultural traditions and when you invade
another area you can get resources from
that area who ate all the bunnies on the
honey sukhothai in the school but we'd
like to hear Danny tell us more about
that a little do some the idea vocaroo
homes in Nevada Oh No
Danny's honey I'll keep it developed
under at all a risotto funnel horizontal
moment at the kid on the skid oh ha ha
ha so being Japanese I wasn't really
sure how best to divide North America
into these 13 different areas but Danny
really stepped into a super helpful
there and had a very interesting
conversation with Paul about that yeah
we there's 13 zones in America and we
tried to define them culturally right
don't my baseball team fandom if you're
in Montana your units will unlock the
cowboy hats and some of the Western
stuff for your clan to wear so they can
have Klan identity with territory Oh
also emotional identity I mean you can
take your home or another one and in
we're also going to be building a
European map for the European audience
with the same kind of cultural tags in
the assets and of course really
important all the multiplayer has a
persistent economy as you can see so
when you ask about conquering a base and
and earning more points to build up your
base unlock more weapons all the things
that make us great persistent ongoing
multiplayer adventure so to speak for
you and your friends there's a lot of as
Lady Gaga son says there are a lot of
layers of gameplay in the multiplayer
and the single-player as well as you can
see there's areas and like all great
combat games there are multiple ways to
approach
every encounter multiple weapons to
choose from and of course this as you're
laughing this is double linking himself
off the second-story balcony yes you do
that it works in single-player and
multiplayer and as I said the acrobatics
the running getting new points of view
on the enemy and attacking the enemy in
neuen and wild ways is really just
provides a great fun factor and a great
sense of fun to this game because if one
thing this game has is a great sense of
fun alright Danny well Scott Danny thank
you guys so much
Inagaki son thank you for coming on
stage and showing us Devil's third and
telling us so much about it I can
definitely see that sense of fun you
guys are going for every game so this we
got a little more fun to show you here
it looks like oh really what do you got
up your sleeve here Oh
and again really important all of these
moves in got our super cruise they're
super fluid and you can interpret that
however you want there's a lot of fluids
but the control set is fantastic and
he's a master of the controller and
playing this game it feels great all
different levels of players can enjoy
the wild campaign excellent well thanks
again for coming on showing off Devils
third can you tell us when this game's
gonna be available and when a booklet
and of course it's going to be on the
Wii U exclusively Hopson by BYU mascot
we're currently in talks with intento
about release day but we can announce
just yet
Borini on o connor vamonos oh no
compassionate ex tyrannous kodomo no
mana mother Janaki ahi na keiki night
ocurro abeba takeno AI na na ki august
oka hey so uh korekara dunno Canasta key
mascara that means T to the outside
we're really happy with how the game is
shaping up but there's just a few more
things that we still have left its week
like some anime ai and things like that
but it's getting really close and we're
excited about announcing soon excellent
well I hope you gentlemen have a great
III thanks again for coming on stage and
folks we are gonna be back here live
with destiny in just a few moments we'll
be with you shortly